la fin d'un projet de 340 en confier par
louis xiv à le nôtre en 760 les jardins
du domaine royal de saint germain en
laye sont en piètre état et le roi
demande à son jardinier de leur redonner
de l'éclat mais cette commande est
restée inachevée après le départ du roi
pour versailles ce projet est aussi
porté par la ville l'état et la
fondation du patrimoine ce jeudi 12
janvier la première pierre du grand
bassin du domaine de saint germain en
laye a été posée en présence du maire
arnaud péricard du préfet jean jacques
brot et de roselyne bachelot la ministre
de la culture les évolutions
technologiques des chemins de fer du rer
avait considérablement altéré cette
perspective unique du château vieux et
de ça et de sa grande pièce d'eau et
finalement les travaux de la ratp nous
permettent de revoir les choses à
quelque chose en quelque sorte malheur
est bon sur le plan sur le plan
patrimonial un projet collectif on à
dire entre le maire l'état la fondation
du patrimoine mais aussi le département
des élus et des mécènes privés puisque
une souscription a été lancée ce projet
innovant pourquoi parce qu'on a mis
autour de la table pour le financer le
département la région évidemment nos
deux principaux partenaires on l'a fait
également avec le ministère de la
culture qu'il a fallu mettre aussi
demandé de financement mais des
partenaires privés des particuliers la
fondation du patrimoine un fonds de
dotation l'entreprise suez cas par cas
ils font des fenêtres ils ont tenu à
participer coût du projet plus de 5
millions d'euros les travaux ont débuté
grâce à l'arrivée du tram 13 et le
tunnel qui le reliera au rer a le bassin
se situe juste au dessus des ouvrages de
la ratp il s'agit du plus grand bassin
d'île de france puisqu'il fera 50 m de
diamètre il permet de reconstituer la
perspective royal d'éloges son
inauguration est prévue le 17 septembre
2022 lors des journées du patrimoine